ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะก็กลับมาเจอกับเรา 2
คนหนึ่งสองนะคะนักเรียนนั่งเล่นยังงง
คนน่ะเราสองคนนอนในวีดีโอระดับอะไรคะ
วีดีโอระดับลีกอินเนอร์ค่ะบีกินเนอร์ฟ้า
นี้
ก็ไม่ดีคลุกหญิงอะไรนะคะสบายดีไหมคะวัน
นี้สบายดีค่ะค่ะครูฟ้าราคะสบายดีไหมคะ
บายดีค่ะสบายดีนะตายถ้าสบายดีเราก็มา
เริ่มคลาสเลยครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะ
วันนี้วัน
เมื่อ
วันศุกร์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันศุกร์ที่ 11
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ 5
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีคศ
5022 นะคะ
2022 นะคะนักเรียน
วันนี้วันอะไรคะครูป๊าเมื่อวานนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดีค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 11 เอาคอกันกับ
ผู้ฟ้าเลยอ่ะมี
รูสด
ก่อนที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 10 ค่ะเดือน
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์
AE พ.ต.ต.ปี
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะค่ะแล้วพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรครับ
ครูฟ้า
พรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 12 ค่ะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
0225 ค่ะน้องก็วันนี้วันศุกร์แล้วแล้ว
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอน
ช่วงเวลาเที่ยง
เที่ยงเที่ยง
กี่นาทีคะ
เที่ยง 55 นาทีค่ะ
12:55 นเป็นเวลากลางวัน
ใช่ไหมคะเป็นเวลากลางวันต่อผู้หญิงกี่โมง
คะครูหญิงนะคะก็จะตรงข้ามกับครูฟ้าสมัย
ครูฟ้าเป็นเวลากลางวันของผู้หญิงก็จะเป็น
เอ่อมันเขียนอะไรคะ 00 แล้วก็
007 เอาแบบไทยแล้วก็น้องคนไทยบอกว่า 20
04:55
วิ่งเป็นเวลากลางคืน
อเมริกาอ่ะอันไหนอะเมริกาแต่ว่าวันนี้นะ
คะครูฟ้าผู้หญิงเนี่ยก็จะมีเกมมาเล่นกับ
ครูฟ้าและนักเรียนหรือ
จีบอะไร
เป็นเกมเกี่ยวกับอวัยวะ
โอ๊ย
ผมกูก็ไม่ใช่หูตา
ปากหัวมือนะทั้งหมดเนี่ยเป็นอวัยวะนะคะ
วันนี้จะมีเกมอวัยวะมาเล่นกับนักเรียน
โอเคเล่นยังไงเดี๋ยวเรา
แค่สกรีนดอร์ต่อได้ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงกำลัง Share  screen  size ไหมคะ
ครูฝากให้ผู้หญิง
และแชทฟรีนมาหรือยังคะมาแล้วนะคะรักที่มา
แล้วราชาแล้วใช่ไหม
อันนี้คือ
อะไรนะคะฟ้านั่งกายใช่ไหมคะจ่ายค่ะดีคือ
ร่างกายแล้วได้รูปเนี่ยเป็นผู้หญิงหรือ
ผู้ชาย
ในรูปเป็นผู้หญิงค่ะจะเป็นผู้หญิงเนาะ
แล้วก็จะผู้หญิงยืนอยู่แล้วก็จะมีรูปอ่า
เล็กๆใช่มั้ย
เล็กๆเล็กๆเล็กๆราคาทรายค่ะเดี๋ยวคู่หญิง
อ่าใส่ตัวเลขดีมั้ยนักเรียนจะได้
ง่ายๆเนาะได้เลยมาถึงนะคะอันนี้มันไม่ใช่
เลขก็จะเป็นแบบนึง
พี่น้องสอง
สาม
สี่
ห้าหก
เจ็ด
แปด
ให้กูฟ้าเขียน
90 นะคะอ่ะทั้งหมด 10 หรอครูฟ้ารูปที่ 1
อวัยวะอะไรคะ
รูปที่ 1 คือหัวเนาะหัว
หัวรูปที่ 2 อะไรคะ
รูปที่ 2 คือหูแต่ไหมหูเรามีหู 2 ข้าง
เนาะหนูซ้าย + ขวานะคะรูปที่ 3 อะไรคะลูก
ที่ 3 คือปากค่ะปาดรูปที่ 4 อะไรคะอ่ะ
โอ๊ยลูกที่ 4 คือแขน
แขนรูปที่ 5 อะไรคะลูกที่ 5 คือขาขารูป
ที่ 6 อะไรคะรูปที่ ๖ คือตา
r7 อะไรคะรู้ 7 คือจมูก
3 รูปที่ 8 อะไรคะลูกที่ 8 คือฟัน
ฟันรูปที่ 9 อะไรคะรูปที่ 9 คือมือจะมือ
มีสองเหมือนกันใช่ไหมจริงแขนก็มีเหรอเออ
แล้วรูปที่ 10 อะไรคะครูฟ้าลูกที่ 10 คือ
เท้าค่ะเท้าอันนี้ก็เป็นอวัยวะทั้งหมด 10
อย่างใช่ไหมอ่ะที่เรามีให้นักเรียนก็จะมี
หัวใช่ไหมคะคือฟ้า
หัวหู
ปากแขน
ขาค่ะๆจมูก
ปันมือและเท้าค่ะค่ะๆทรายสิบอย่างหรอกที่
เป็นอวัยวะข้างนอกมองเห็นได้
ผู้หญิงอะไรคะหัว
เอาไว้ทำอะไร
หัวหรอหัวก็เอาไว้ใส่หมวกค่ะครูฟ้าใช่ไหม
หัวไว้ใส่หมวกเด็กผู้หญิงมีหมวกแล้วก็ใส่
หมวกนักหัวเอาไว้ใส่บวกค่ะ
ตาเอาไว้ทำอะไรคะอาเอาไว้มาดูทีวี
ดูดูทีวี
ดูทีวีดูไซส์ดูเซรี่ Wolf คอมพิวเตอร์
อ่ะดู YouTube  OK ตาเอาไว้ดู YouTube นะ
คะดู YouTube เข้า Festival ไทย
understand  Thai ด้วยนะคะดูถูก
ใช่ค่ะ
ปากเอาไว้ทำอะไร
เนี่ยไว้พูดไปพูดสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงค่ะพูด
เนาะพูดภาษาไทยในผู้หญิงร้องเพลงได้ไหม
จ๊ะได้นักเตะหน้าได้ร้องเพลงได้แต่วันนี้
เราจะไม่พูดหรอกพูดภาษาไทย
แขนเอาไว้ทำอะไรคะแล้วแขนเนี่ยเวลาที่นัก
เรียนฟังภาษาไทยแล้วนักเรียนออก
ก็ไม่เข้าใจสมัยแขนก็เอาไว้ยกมีคำถามยก
เลิกไม่เข้าใจก็เออคุณครูไม่เข้าใจก็ยก
แขนค่ะๆเอาไว้ยกเวลาไม่เข้าใจเอาโอเคเอา
ไว้
[เพลง]
ยกดัมเบลยกดัมเบล
ยกดัมเบลเออแผนเอาไว้ยกดัมเบลขอบคุณฟ้ายก
ดัมเบล
หาราคะขาหาเนี่ยนะคะเอาไว้ยืนใช่มายืนแบบ
นี้ใช่ไหมยืน
ๆ
เดินได้ไหมเท้า
อะหรอ
เออขาไว้ยืนน่ะจะไปยืนปั้น
ได้ๆและจักรยานแต่ไว้ขาอะไรอ่ะจะว่าเอา
ไว้ยืนก็ได้ใช่ไหมยืนรูปนี้ก็ยืนยืนไปอ่ะ
ป้าเอาไว้ทำตาไปแล้วตาไว้หนู YouTube โข
ไปทำไมโหเอาไว้ฟังภาษาไทย
เวลาดู YouTube ไปด้วยฟังไปด้วยฟังภาษา
ไทย
โอเคเลยฟังภาษาไทยนะคะค่ะ
จมูกเอาไว้ทำอะไรค่ะจมูกเนี่ยเอาไว้ดมใช่
ไหมมีค่ะสมมติมีเทียนแล้วก็จง
ของเนาะเอาไว้ดมค่ะจมูกเอาไว้ดมดงฟัน
มาปั้นฟันเนี่ยเอาไว้เคี้ยวใช่ไหมสมมติ
นักเรียนดื่มน้ำแล้วมีน้ำแข็งเนาะน้ำแข็ง
และก็กลับ
เขียวน่ะเขียวน้ำปั่นกะคอมบี้
เฮ้ยกดเป็นคน
เดียวเขียวก็ได้
กลับไม่ได้มือ
เบอร์เอาไว้
หยิบโทรศัพท์ใช้เวลาโทรศัพท์วางอยู่เอา
มือเราก็หยิบโทรศัพท์นะคะ
หยิบลิปสติกได้ค่ะอ่าหยิบหรือว่าจับเมาส์
จะไม่มีเมาส์ก็เอาไว้จับเมาส์ได้อะนี้มือ
เอาไว้ตก
เก่งมากขอ
ตบมือ
เอาเสียได้
เท้าออยทำอะไรคะเช้าเอาไว้เดินไงเหมือน
ครูฟ้าบอกใช่มั้ยขาก็ได้แต่เท้าก็เอาไว้
เดินเดินๆ
เนี่ยสายอ่ะเดี๋ยวโอเคเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงจะพูด
ว่าทำอะไรแล้วครูฟ้าก็บอกว่าเป็นอวัยวะ
อะไรนะคะ R ได้เก็บ
ข้อแรงเนาะอวัยวะอะไรเอาไว้พูดพูดภาษาไทย
พูดภาษาไทย
เฮ้ย
พูดภาษาถ้ามา
ปาดๆอันที่สองอวัยวะอ่ะจะไปเอาไว้ดู
YouTube คอมเพลนสิเบิ้ลไทย understand
Thai  not  Do  Do  YouTube
ป่าค่ะค่ะอันที่ 3 อวัยวะอะไรเอาไว้ยืน
ยืนของเด็กผู้หญิงคนนี้ก็ยืนเอาไว้ยืนยืน
ขาค่ะ
4 อวัยวะอะไรเอาไว้ตัดชุดฟ้าบอกปลาชอบดู
ซอมบี้นั้นล่ะกัด
ฟันห่าปั่นต่อไปข้อที่ 5 อวัยวะอะไรเอา
ไว้ถือ
กับโทรศัพท์ใช่มั้ยปิดรู้จักอ่ะจับจับจับ
โทรศัพท์หยิบในจิ้มโทรศัพท์ก็จะอ่ะอวัยวะ
อะไรเอาไว้อ่าหยิบโทรศัพท์ครับลุงฟ้า
มือค่ะแม่
ต่อไปเอาอวัยวะอะไรเอาไว้ดมสนิทแล้วก็ดม
ดมเห้ย
จมูกค่ะอ่ะอวัยวะอะไรเอาไว้เดิน
งู
เท้าค่ะ
อวัยวะอะไรเวลาไม่เข้าใจแล้วเอาไว้ยก
แขนหักค่ะค่ะอ๋อขอโทษยกเบลช่วยดัมเบลยก
ดัมเบลก็ได้นะยกมือก็ได้นะคะเอาอวัยวะ
อะไรเอาไว้ใส่หมวก
อวัยวะอะไรหัวค่ะ 5 หัวสมัยคะอวัยวะอะไร
เอาไว้และฟังภาษาไทย
คู่หูค่ะ
หนูใช่ไหมคะโอเคเนาะฟัง
พูดใช่ไหมคะเดี๋ยวเราจะมาเช็คว่านักเรียน
จำได้ไหมสมัยที่เราพูดไปนะคะได้แค่กริ่ง
ก็จะมีรูปของเด็กผู้ชายน้องกันที่พอนะคะ
[เพลง]
สิ่งต้องลบรถก่อนใช่ไหมคะครูฝากให้ค่ะ
เคลียร์ก่อนคุณอ่ะครูฟ้าช่วยใส่ตัวเลขใน
วงกลมได้ไหมคะ
เรียง 1 จาก 1 อะไร
หนึ่งก็คือตาเอ้อ 2 จมูกสมัย 3
ขาหรอไม่มีขา 2 อันนะคะแกะออกข่าว
ครูมาช่วยเอาสีไปที่ฟันได้ไหมคะจะได้
เหมือนกันเอาเขาออกก็เราไม่มี
สีไปที่อุ้ยเดี๋ยวนะเคลียร์กัน
4  1  1  2  3  3  4 วันที่ขาไหมค่ะ 4
ไว้ที่ขาอันละ 50 ว่าจะเอาให้
หรออ๋ออ๋อ
666 โหใช่ไหมคะ 7 มือ
8 แขน
ก้าวเท้าหรอค่ะอันนี้ไม่มีนะกูกากาออกไป
เลยค่ะอันนั้น
No ไม่มีก็จะมีตา
จมูก
ปาก
ขา
หัว
หมู
เมืองมือถือ
มีแผน
แล้วก็ถามเขาใช่ไหมเท้าหรอ
ตาไว้เดี๋ยวเราจะมีเกมนะครับครูผู้หญิง
เนี่ยจะพูดว่าทำอะไรแล้วให้นักเรียนคิด
ว่าเป็นอวัยวะอะไร
ล่ะอย่างแต่เราจะให้เวลานิดหน่อยเนาะโอเค
อ่ะอวัยวะอะไรเอาไว้ฟังภาษาไทย
ฟังภาษาไทย
1  2
3  4  5 ก็แล้วห้าวินาทีอะไรคะอวัยวะ
อะไรไว้ฟังภาษาไทย
หูค่ะหูเบอร์หงส์
อันนี้ 2 อวัยวะอะไรเอาไว้ใส่หมวก
อ่าใส่หมวกร้อนๆใช่ไหมร้อนอ่ะก็ต้องรับ
ใส่หมวก 1  2  2  3  4  4  5 อวัยวะอะไร
ครับครูฟ้า
หัวค่ะหัวเบอร์ 5 เนาะสบายเอาอวัยวะอะไร
เอาไว้ดู
YouTube คอมพรีเฮนสิเบิ้ลไทย understand
Thai
I เอ่อ 1  2  3  4  5 อะไรคะครูฟ้าอาค่ะ
ตาๆอวัยวะอะไรเอาไว้พูดภาษาไทยพูดเนาะ
สวัสดีค่ะพูด 1  2  3  4
แต่ถ้าอะไรคะครูฟ้า
ปากค่ะเนาะโดย 3 อวัยวะอะไรเอาไว้ดม
กดเดี๋ยวไปจะไม่ให้สั้นดม 1  2  3  4  4
5  5 อะไรคะครูฟ้า
จมูกค่ะจมูก
อวัยวะอะไรเอาไว้หยิบโทรศัพท์หยิบลิปสติก
1  2  3  4  4  5  5 อะไรคะครูฟ้ามือค่ะ
เย้
อวัยวะอะไรเอาไว้ยกดัมเบลสวยแบบโอ้ยก
ดัมเบล
2  2  3  4  5 อะไรคะครูฟ้าอ่ะมีแผนค่ะ
แผนนะอะอวัยวะอะไรเอาไว้
เดินตอนเดินใช่ไหมจากบ้านแล้วก็ไปโรง
เรียนเดิน 1  2  3  4  4  5  5 อะไรครับ
ครูฟ้า
เท้าค่ะ
เท้าแล้วก็สุดท้ายขาใช่ไหมคะเอาไว้ทำอะไร
เอาไว้ยืนน้องเอาไว้ยืนนะคะใส่แล้วนี้
ทั้งหมดก็เป็น
เกมอวัยวะใช่ไหมที่เราเอามาเล่นกับนัก
เรียนภาษานักเรียนถูกเท่าไหร่ผิดเท่าไหร่
ก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะวันนี้เราก็ไปก่อน
นะคะแล้วเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้าไปบายสวัสดี
ค่ะพี่